[Musique]
je suis né à moscou qui est la capitale
de la russie
je suis arrivé ici j'avais 3 ans dire
que je suis québécois mais je garde
toujours mais mes origines russes et on
est en exqi un restaurant de cuisine
d'inspiration russe
je pense que ça manque un peu cette
représentation de la communauté russe de
l'europe de l'est ici de la nouvelle
génération aussi donc je voulais cet
aspect leur amour et aboie médias et
restauratrice elle tente de conserver
mais aussi de partager toute la culture
russe elle a créé un lieu qui invite à
la découverte la cuisine russe son
cocktail elle provient de cuisine de
différents pays qui sont les anciennes
républiques de l'union soviétique
donc ça permet d'avoir plusieurs savoir
que différentes particularités
non
en cuisine le chef prépare les mets
traditionnels comme les pelmeni sibérien
une pâtes farcies de trois viandes
plonger dans l'eau bouillante puis
sauter à la poêle ou encore la version
ukrainienne les varenikis qui sont
farcis de pommes de terre avec un oignon
bécane et crème sur l'incontournable de
la cuisine de l'europe de l'est ça
serait le boersch fait à base de
betterave
ce que je peux te dire c'est qu'il ya
autant de recettes de borges qui existe
qui lie à je pense de famille dans
l'europe de l'est
nous on est ce qui on le fait avec une
version végétarienne des fois lorsqu'on
essaie de dire qui a inventé le boersch
là le débat peut être très long c'est
sûr qu'il ya des pays qui ont ré dominé
dans certains plats mais je pense que
c'est la symbiose du tout qui compte à
la fin
en russie on dit qu'ouvrir la table
ainsi en toute convivialité
on partage les mêmes en prenant une
petite gorgée de votre cas bien glacé ce
qui est très important de notre cuisine
c'est à cause qui peut être chaud au
froid zakouskis et des hors d'oeuvre qui
sont mangés tout au long du repas des
fois accompagnée d'une balle piquée de
votre coeur les acoustiques populaires
sont par exemple la salade olivier fait
de pommes de terre les tomates fermenté
ou encore la salade de carottes
donc en plus du côté asiatique de la
russie puis on retrouve plus d'écouté
plus marquants de l'ail de la coriandre
que ce qu'ils font dans le côté européen
on a le côté plus asiatique
ça fait comme
différentes saveurs en bouche si l'autre
cas pas de schubert le hareng dans son
manteau de fourrure c'est à l'art en
amont sur recouverte de pommes de terre
de betteraves et d'une mince couche de
mayonnaise
moi personnellement c'est mon club
préféré
bienvenue à l'arc à la fca qui est en
fait une petite épicerie voulu présenter
quelques produits qu'on peut retrouver
dans une oeuvre en russie c'est sûr qui
a dit et le thé une partie vraiment
important de la culture russe on à la
confiture d'ailleurs les russes ils
mangent souvent leur thé avec de la
confiture sur les craquelins et donc
justement tout seul
une manière assez traditionnel de boire
le thé
c'est au retour d'un voyage en russie en
compagnie de sa mère et de sa soeur qui
nie l'idée d'ouvrir un restaurant c'est
vraiment espérer de la ville de
saint-pétersbourg qui est la capitale
culturelle de la russie
l'allée principale à saint petersbourg
s'appelle nobs qui prospecte sur cet
aléa toutes les petites entreprises les
petits cafés les petites bibliothèques
j'ai vraiment voulu ramener cette
ambiance ici et si ce qu'on appelle le
nouveau requis une cour en fait avec la
murale à petit verdure et s'apprête donc
à beaucoup de belcourt l'artiste mirren
naceur de médias a créé le décor ainsi
que sa mère par exemple ce que
l'écolière c'est correct
qu'importe un tablier comme ça blanc
parce que ça ça vient un peu de l'union
soviétique donc on voulait vraiment que
ça soit représentatif de la réalité
vamara pu vraiment nous aider avec ça on
s'en moque que aulas bois qui est plus
dans l'ambiance appartement je vous ai
campagne
bienvenue dans la clape tire donc et si
on a voulu reproduire un petit
appartement heureuse vraiment typique
avec les petits oeuvre d'or de la russie
où ça me rappelle vraiment l'appartement
de mes grands parents
donc ça a été vraiment l'image initiale
que j'avais en tête avec laquelle on est
parti pour faire ce gain
[Musique]
marlène et le conjoint de mme il ya il
coordonne l'équipe en cuisine et c'est
lui qui confectionne un des plats
classiques
le catch à poulies un bateau du fromage
refaire un cheese bande originale on
utilise du fromage mozzarella râpée
fromage mozzarella ferait aussi du
fromage heures gien qui s'appelle du
sorgho ni le catch up public est un plat
géorgie on fait juste prendre la
fourchette puis on veut mélanger le
concours on fait juste prendre un long
de la côte et on va tromper dedans puis
on mange bien tenu ma pitié pas bon
appétit en reste j'ai peut-être pris un
lieu que j'avais envie d'inviter mes
amis qui sont parues ce venir ici reçu
par russ propre art
c'est quand même une partie importante
de mon identité donc pouvoir la
conserver puis la partager avec les
autres c'est quelque chose de l'fun
[Musique]